turning point for me when i realized
that the ignorance
in this world is unbelievable
because uh just earlier uh in my pitch i
had told that how 12 million
girls are actually subject to this for
uh modern day slavery
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
and is sponsored by leumitech hippo
insurance touring
upwards labs and hillel at stanford i
just love the intersection of ai and
social
impact meet anna yusella the ceo and
founder of we in courage
anna is an entrepreneur with 10 plus
years of experience in the retail sector
as a teacher and a consultant in the
field of trends profitability and
marketing
her ambition and interest in future
trends and new technologies
as well as her vision and determination
to prevent forced marriages and empower
women
led her to build an impact startup we
encourage
they build a conversational ai tool for
the victims of domestic violence
and a fundraising platform for causes
empowering women and girls
anna usela thank you for joining me all
the way from finland
how are you thank you i'm doing good
enjoying the snow
finally here and my kids are joining
that
uh enjoying that too and uh i'm happy to
be here thank you for the invitation
of course of course i i always love
talking to people that
you know they're while they're there the
work that they're doing is inspiring
their journey
is also inspiring and i think that your
transition from
from fashion to retail to uh to now you
know
really a startup and trying to grow a
community and growing technological
solutions
to to help level the playing field and
and you know help
women and girls around the world with
all sorts of issues that that you'll
describe to me soon
and i think it's inspiring but but your
overall you know conversation and
discussion about what it takes to really
start something and go against the fears
i think is just as inspiring so anna
start us off tell me a little bit about
yourself how do you get started with
your journey all the way back from when
you were studying fashion
thank you yes it's it's quite
interesting story even for myself
because i never thought about doing
anything like this so
uh kind of the women empowerment of
course it has always been
quite natural and self-evident for me
because as a finnish lady
i am kind of very accustomed to the
gender equality and
and it's kind of like natural for me but
um i was also very passionate about the
retail
about uh visual merchandising i actually
teach visual merchandisers how to
measure the
effectiveness of those displays and for
the retailers why stock management is so
important and how it affects on the
overall profitability and
such so it was quite interesting
uh when i saw the documentary about
an afghan girl who wanted to be a rapper
and the long story short the documentary
maker ended up
buying sonita free from her own family
because they were
they were forcing her into
marriage and uh her story ended nicely
she is now studying music in united
states and then she's rapping
against child marriages but uh it was a
turning point for me
i i got so frustrated and uh angry and
and started to think that
how are we still living in in year 2016
in a world where girls are being forced
into marriage
and of course things are not that simple
but basically the the kind of the amount
that she was
kind of freed from her family was just
two thousand dollars
and i started to think that how on earth
we we are doing something about it if
it's just about the money
as it's basically kind of like when you
go down
to the roots of all it's basically
because the families don't have enough
money to
raise the the child uh which is a girl
and i started to think that what if we
could use um
people's money to to purchase these
girls free
and it was kind of like the starting
point of course it's kind of like not
not that uh simple and not that easy and
not that straightforward but it was kind
of like the starting point
and back in those days i got very very
interested in blockchain and artificial
intelligence what's happening in that
sphere uh how it's affecting on retail
and
and things like this and i started to
think that what if what if we just
used blockchain create a smart wallet
for uh
donors and a smart wallet for the family
and the girl
and we could use this peer-to-peer
incentivizing system so that it would
become
economically more beneficial for the
families to actually keep the girl at
school so they could get
a monthly payment for keeping the girl
at school
and with just a small amount
like 25 euros we could actually per
month we could actually
uh keep the girl at school in those very
low economic
countries and and that's kind of like
stuck in my head that
um i i it took a few years for me
to actually clear the fear out of my
system to actually
start doing something about this issue i
i kept the idea inside of me and and was
thinking that
when i'm 50 years old then and
successful
woman then i can start doing something
about this but
uh kind of my my world decided
differently
and and uh i started kind of
moving towards the idea and
i i had been learning uh
when i was uh investigating the
blockchain and and seeing what's
happening there i noticed that there is
this uh
association in finland and i joined one
of their meetings and
and told about my idea to a couple of
guys over there and
they were telling me that that's an
awesome idea you should go and
pitch that into a blockchain summit
that's
coming up in in couple of weeks and uh
of course i was very very new to all of
this and i was like okay
what's pitching i have no idea and um
of course i had i had to learn about it
and i uh
googled and and drafted the pitch and
and went on the stage uh after a couple
of weeks
and the worst thing happened to me and
um
the first jury member started laughing
at me
and telling me that how stupid are you
that uh who would marry off their uh who
would force their
daughters into marriage and uh
that was quite a turning point for me
when i realized that the ignorance
in this world is unbelievable
because uh just earlier in my pitch i
had told that how 12 million girls
are actually subject to this for uh
modern day slavery
so 33 000 girls per day
and now uh considering that coronavirus
it's even increasing so that was kind of
like the the starting point
uh luckily the other jury member opened
his network and and he
encouraged me to to kind of like take
this
uh forward and then i was in the
crossroads
uh kind of do i continue with my uh
current company
and and uh build my uh entrepreneurial
journey uh in the retail sphere or
do i take a leap of faith and and start
doing something that it's
very very risky without no knowledge
about
startup world without no understanding
of coding or the
development but start
utilizing technology to empower women so
that's kind of like my story in
in very short in in a nutshell
unbelievable
well first of all i think that it takes
a lot of courage and and i think that
that that's already inspiring as its own
and what i'd love to
to hear from you a little bit more is
about this you know this insight that
you have into
this horrible marketplace that you're
describing right i mean usually when we
talk about companies and startups we
talk about
you know these great marketplaces where
you have the you have the seller you
have the buyer and or you have the
driver and the writer right in terms of
transportation well here you have a
really
sort of nasty marketplace where you have
you know the the people who are forcing
their their
children their girls into marriage and
the buyers are
are sort of funding this family and it
all stems from this economic inequality
this
right this economical gap because i'm
guessing no no parent wants to
force their child into marriage but but
you know they might they might have to
do it out of necessity
if there is just no other option for
them to put food on the table right so
so you're coming in and saying well how
about we you know we open up this
marketplace and we
we we provide an alternative solution so
that
so that we can you know don't have to to
go on these horrible acts
how do you unders how do you go about
thinking about this
alternative solution and thinking how
does this actually tangibly play out
yes that was actually kind of the the
most
important uh important and interesting
part of the whole journey because uh
considering that all my networks all my
knowledge
all my ex experience and expertise was
on the retail
and all of the sudden i i was there uh
having this very very uh kind of uh
big urge to do something about this
matter
and what i had to do first of course i i
needed to start studying the whole
thing what's happening i i had all my
own thoughts and ideas that what's
what's the situation but
of course i had to dig deeper and um
i started to doing uh research what what
what's happening how
how are things uh uh going what's the
cultural aspects what are the
uh cultural and uh religious uh
aspects in this and and i uh joined in
different
uh uh places where i could learn more
about impact and creating
impact and how do you do the change in
in these
types of uh cases and i learned that of
course it's not going to be easy
it's not uh it's not kind of like
something that i can just
do quickly and and there is no quick fix
it's going to be
a long long time journey and um
what i realized is that
this is not something that it's
happening actually over there i was
naive and i thought that it's
it's kind of like the third world
problem but i realized that
these are the same uh issues that are
happening in western world also for the
for the girls from a
certain cultural background they they
are facing the same issues even here in
finland
so girls are disappearing from schools
uh they are going to
uh fgm and uh there are different types
of
uh cultural and religious traditions
that
follow them uh no matter where they live
and i realized that it's not something
that i can kind of uh
consider of doing somewhere out there
but i have to uh realize and understand
that uh
it's a global issue it's a global
problem
and of course like always in startup
world
nothing comes easy it it takes a lot of
persistence and and kind of
determination if you start moving
towards something
bigger than yourself and i realized that
it's
it's not going to be easy to start just
kind of like taking some technology and
then you
you kind of think that okay i'm able to
fix the world like this it's it's not
working like that so uh the first
uh kind of bump in the road became from
the finnish
uh law so in finland uh the fundraising
law is one of the tightest in the world
so that was kind of like the first
barrier when i realized that okay i
cannot build that kind of incentivizing
system
in finland because uh we simply cannot
have
ngos on our system who are supporting
and helping
uh these women and girls because they
have to be registered in finland
so um the first thing that we had to do
is to kind of figure out the different
way of helping and supporting these
women and girls
and uh it led to us uh creating the
prototype
it's simple just a wordpress site and
and we decided to
just test uh how how we can
arrange a place for girls in school so
we
we did our first pilot testing uh with
that and we managed to get
three girls uh in the school uh from
india
and and that was very very good uh thing
for us and we are happy and proud about
that
and um one thing that has been kind of
key
in in what we are building is to
understand those who would be using it
who we are trying to help
actually and uh for that i started
uh doing research and interview uh ngos
that are helping women and girls here in
finland and i started asking their needs
what kind of
problems they face in in fundraising
needs they have and they actually came
up with completely different need that i
thought that they have the
the problems with fundraising and and
certainly they have
but uh the bigger pain was this that
they are facing many women uh with
domestic violence and violence in their
relationships
but they don't have resources and people
in place to help and support them
so many of the ngos are kind of uh
the the entity that is helping women uh
with violence
and uh just a record finland is actually
the second most violent country for
women
in europe which is quite staggering
considering
how we are perceived as a very gender
equal quantry
and i realized that okay if you are
having a human operated chat that's open
only couple hours per week
it means that the need and the offering
are not
meeting because many times these women
who need someone to help them
uh it kind of like they cannot be there
just to wait for
uh thursday at 2 p.m to to talk
the need might appear in in different
times and places and
then i started uh considering that why
don't you use artificial intelligence
to help and support uh when you are
offline that they could talk to
uh the the uh
with the bot so that uh it can for
example give guidance and support and
help
uh meanwhile so uh that was the starting
point when
uh we started uh creating and ideating
the
the bot that we are currently building
uh i know
and um it was very interesting journey
because
uh also with with this idea that we kind
of
uh combine these two uh platforms so we
we have tested now the fundraising
platform and now we are
uh concentrating on building forward
with the
ai tool and i have realized with that as
well that
the most important thing is to
talk with people who would be using it
so we are
very user-centric we don't take the
technology and try to fit it into their
needs but rather we try to co-create it
with those who would be using it and i
realized that it's
it takes time it's much more time
consuming but
it's kind of building the base and the
ground
for what you are trying to create
because when you are creating a change
when you are trying to help someone
you need to have those people with you
who are you building the solution to and
it's not maybe the easiest and fastest
way
but uh from our point of view it's the
only way
right how do you actually go about
finding these women then
because you know obviously you're you're
you're in one location a lot of them are
another location
it can't be easy you know in the first
place to to locate them and then have
them
have an open and honest conversation
about what they're going through and
what they really need
in in order to in order to you know go
go through and be comfortable so
how do you actually go about finding the
right users for this
yes that's that was actually a quite
interesting
part of this whole project because when
we realized that we have to
interview those uh uh we we call them in
finland they're called like uh
experian uh experts by experience so
there
are these women who have suffered from
violence
and who have survived and who are then
sharing their knowledge their
expertise they might be training
professionals they might be
uh attending supportive peer groups and
and so on and many of these women that
we have been
interviewing are actually the ones who
have been openly speaking
about what what has happened to them so
uh
what i did i i simply contacted them
i told them that what uh i kind of i
read
read did a research of those
who i could find and then i contacted
them
some of them were kind of given to me by
someone that i know who had the network
of those people so
it it it was something that i had to do
kind of like on the
on the background to do the research
find out those people
and then uh have an interview with them
and um
in addition to that we have been
partnering with
uh three different ngos who then
have helped us also to find those who
could speak with us
who could uh give their expertise and
knowledge about the subject
amazing amazing anna what is one thing
you would tell
you know people that are you know
perhaps they're not intact perhaps
they're not you know
currently entrepreneurs but they have
this idea they have this urge that they
want to do something they want to
solve some meaningful problem but but
they're facing a similar
fear or uncertainty that you experienced
before starting this what
what would be some things that you would
say to them as they go on their journey
yes i would say to them that uh
investigate the feeling and the motives
behind it
kind of uh what what is what is the
need kind of like from from your own
point of view
are you are you doing it from the ego is
it something that you want
uh to get fame or fortune uh by doing it
or is it
a genuine feeling of wanting to do
something to do to use your own skills
to make the world a better place because
this is not the easy path this is kind
of like the more complicated path when
you
when you start creating an impact
because what i'm very grateful
for is that many of those who have kind
of gone before me
have given such a great uh advices and
and ideas for uh to take into
consideration for example
uh sometimes your intentions might be
very good
but if you don't know the people that
you are building it
for it might be that you end up doing
more harm
than right so uh especially when you are
considering to help people in completely
different cultural different market that
you
are not well aware of there might be
some kind of pitfalls that you have to
take
into consideration before starting doing
it
so i would suggest that do a thorough
research
before you uh go forward
learn about the subject just use your
time
uh it took me uh the first year
to just re do the research to learn
about the problem to understand the
people who are uh having this need and
and so on
and uh only after that i decided to
establish the company
uh and and so on so i would suggest that
do the research and see if you are still
feeling the urge
so when you get deeper uh down to the
rabbit hole so so to say uh you you can
see that
is it really your passion because it
takes perseverance you have to be
very determined wonderful anna thank you
so much for spending the time with me
all the way from finland i really
appreciate it and before we leave out
the most important question which is
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
thank you yes uh i would describe myself
as a
bold visionary path maker
i love that i love that i think and i
think it you know it shines through
this whole episode so anna thank you
very very much best of luck with we
encourage and everything that you're
doing and the inspiration you're
providing for women
to women around the world and for and
for helping you know
bring you know both help a lot of
millions of women potentially live
better and healthier
and more sustainable lives but really
just bridging the equality gap that we
have
and bringing it to the attention of the
western world as well that i think
that's
you know that story that you have with
the judges and
you know not not really being able that
ignorance or not being able to really
understand or fathom what's happening
i think that's part of the core issues
and i think that you know beyond the
amazing work that you're doing for the
women i think
it's such an educational feat that
you're taking on here
and that i think it's really inspiring
so thank you and stay safe and stay
healthy
thank you same to stay safe
you